Let's do some more practice
word problems.
Patricia is building a sand
box for her daughter.
It is to be 5 feet wide
and 8 feet long.
So let me draw that.
So the 5 feet wide-- it
is to be 5 feet wide.
So there you go.
That's 5 feet right there.
And 8 feet long.
I'll do that in orange.
8 feet long.
So this is like if we're
looking down
into the sand box.
8 feet long.
So the sand box, if we're
looking down on it, would look
something like that.
That would be 5 feet.
And this side over here
would also be 8 feet.
All right, she wants the height
of the sand box to be 4
inches above the height
of the sand.
OK.
So if we were to draw the sand
box like this-- so if you were
to draw it-- so that's 8.
That distance right
there is 5 feet.
And then there is some height,
which I think we're going to
have to figure out.
Let me draw the whole
box just like that.
The sand is going to
fill a certain
amount of the sand box.
So the sand is going to fill
maybe until right over there.
So that's how much the sand is
going to fill of the sand box.
All of that is sand.
And she wants the height of the
sand box to be 4 inches
above the height of the sand.
So she wants this distance right
here, the amount that
the height goes above the sand,
itself, to be 4 inches--
or a third of a foot, depending
how you want to
think about it.
Now she has 30 cubic
feet of sand.
She has 30 cubic feet of sand.
So this sand right here
is 30 feet cubed.
How high should the
sand box be?
So this information right here,
the volume of the sand,
tells us, using it, we can
figure out how high the level
of the sand will be.
Let's do it this way.
Let's call l-- let
me just use x.
Let's say x is the height
of the sand.
x is equal to height of sand.
So the total volume of our sand
is going to be the height
of the sand times the
length of the box.
Times 8 times the width
of the box.
Times 5.
And this is going to be the
total volume which they told
us is 30 cubic feet.
It is 30 cubic feet.
We're taking x feet times
8 feet times 5 feet.
So we'll get 30 feet cubed
if we were to keep
track of the units.
So what is this?
8 times 5 is 40.
So we get 40x is equal to 30.
If we divide both sides by
40-- both sides of the
equation by 40--
let me do that.
You divide both sides by 40, you
get x is equal to-- that
just becomes an x.
X is equal to 30/40, where
it equals 3/4 of a foot.
So this right here is going
to be 3/4 of a foot.
Now what is 3/4 of a foot?
Let's see, 3/4 of a foot.
We know that there are
12 inches per foot.
The feet cancel out.
12 times 3/4 is what?
You can divide the 12
by 4 and get a 3.
Divide the 4 by 4
and you get a 1.
You get 3 times 3.
This is 9 inches.
9 inches.
So the height of the sand
right there is 9 inches.
Now she wants the height of the
sand box to be 4 inches
above the height of the sand.
So this is 9 inches.
She wants 4 more inches.
So what she wants the height of
the sand box-- it should be
the 9 inches of the height of
the sand plus 4, which is
equal to 13 inches.
And we are done.
Let's do the next problem.
It was a sale day in Macy's,
and everything was 20% less
than the regular price.
Peter bought a pair of shoes.
And using a coupon, he got an
additional 10%-- let me do
that in a different color.
He got an additional 10% off
the discounted price.
The price he paid was $36.
The price he paid for the
shoes-- let me do that in a
different color-- the price he
paid for the shoes was $36.
How much did it originally
cost?
So let's just use-- so x is
equal to original cost. There
was just a regular
sale on that day.
Everything was 20% less than
the regular price.
So using that information, on
that day, if you wanted to buy
the shoes, the cost of the shoes
would be x minus 0.20x,
which is equal to 0.8x, right?
If you have 20% off of a price,
you're going to be
paying 80% of the
original price.
So this is the price that
everyone would have paid
without a coupon.
And that's what that line is
telling us right there.
Now Peter got a pair of shoes,
and using a coupon, got an
additional 10% off of this.
An additional 10% off of that.
So he's paying 10%
less than this.
Or another way to think of it
is, he only had to pay 90% of
this price.
If you take 0.8x and from that
you subtract 10% of this-- so
from that, you subtract 10% of
that-- of 0.8x, this is the
same thing.
All right.
This is a 1 time 0.8x.
This is the same thing
as 1 minus 0.1.
So this is the same thing.
This is equal to 90% of 0.8x.
And it might actually be
very natural for you to
go straight to this.
It's natural for me.
If I'm paying 20% less than the
regular price, that means
I'm going to pay 80% of
the regular price.
And if I get an additional 10%
off of that, that means I'm
only going to pay 90% of that.
So this is what he's
going to pay.
And they tell us that
price is $36.
That price is equal to $36.
So if we want to figure
out x, well, we could
multiply 0.9 times 0.8.
Let's do that.
So 0.9 times 0.8.
9 times 8 is 72.
We have two numbers behind
the decimal.
One, two.
So it's 0.72.
So you get 0.72x
is equal to 36.
Or maybe we could say 72/100
x is equal to 36.
Or we could even say this is
same thing as-- what is it?
That's the same thing
as 36/50, right?
36/50 x is equal to 36.
And this isn't even in lowest
common forms. This is the same
thing as 18/25.
But I like this number because
I have a 36 here.
And so I can multiply both sides
by the inverse of this.
50/36 times this.
I have to do to both sides
of the equation.
36's cancel out.
50's cancel out.
And you're left with
x is equal to $50.
The shoes originally cost $50.
Next question.
Rosa has saved all year, and
wishes to spend the money she
has on new clothes
and a vacation.
She will spend 30% more on the
vacation then on the clothes.
So let's say, let's say that C
is amount spent on clothes.
She's going to spend 30%
more on the vacation.
So let's say V is equal to the
amount spent on vacation.
Well, they just told us that the
vacation-- she's going to
spend 30% more than
on the clothes.
So the vacation is going to be
equal to the amount she spends
on the clothes plus 30%
of the amount she
spends on the clothes.
And this is the same
thing as 1.3.
1.3 times the amount she
spends on the clothes.
That's how much she's going
to spend on the vacation.
Now, if she saved $1,000 in
total, how much money, to the
nearest whole dollar, can she
spent on the vacation?
So between V and C, she
can only spend $1,000.
So V, vacation, plus her clothes
can only be $1,000.
So we know what the vacation
is in terms of the clothes.
We can do a little
substitution.
The vacation is going to be
1.3 times the clothes.
So we can substitute there.
So you have 1.3 times
the clothes.
That's the vacation expenditure,
plus the amount
she spends on the clothes
is equal to 1,000.
This is 1.3 plus 1 is 2.3, times
the amount she spends on
clothes will be equal
to $1,000.
Divide both sides by 2.3.
I'll get the calculator
out for this one.
So we have 1,000 divided by
2.3 is equal to $434.78.
So C is equal to-- I already
forgot the number-- 434.78.
$434.78.
So if that's the amount she
spends on clothes, the rest of
her money is going to be
spent on a vacation.
So her vacation is going
to be 1,000 minus this.
So her vacation expenditure
is going to
be 1,000 minus $434.78.
I'll do the calculator
for this one.
Let's see.
Let's make this into
a negative number.
And then, let's add
1,000 to it.
And we get $565.22.
And I'll leave it up
to you to check it.
This is how much she spends
on the vacation.
These add up to $1,000.
And this should be exactly 30%
more than this amount, the
amount she spends
on her clothes.